I think everybody defaults into what
comes easy to them greatness comes from
adversity and looking the challenge in
the eye and having the intestinal
fortitude to step up and go after it but
it's just making every [ __ ] minute
count every minute has to count every
minute past account if you want so much
because you just don't have as many of
them as you think you just don't I think
it's easy for you Fitness entrepreneur
to do the push-ups to do the squats to
do the deadlifts because that's how you
got here you started fitness now you
want to make some money by having those
guns or that ass right and so I think
you default into what's easy without
recognizing what's hard it was hard for
me over these last 16 months to get into
better shape it was easy for me to build
50 million dollar businesses just the
truth I know how hard last 16 months
waking up every day not eating
everything I wanted and by doing the
work was for me that's the same thing
that's going on in the fitness
entrepreneur fitness launch open or
space is of course you're spending more
time to work out sessions because you
want to pass on replying to everybody
you want to pass off you know the
marketing you want to pass off doing
every podcast you want to pass off the
creative on Instagram that will get you
business versus the vanity of getting a
bunch of luck likes cuz you look good so
you want to pass off all that other
stuff the same way that I wanted to pass
off getting up running working out
lifting squatting stretching I didn't
want to do it good [ __ ] but I could work
18 hours a day
you're just a verse of me one reason I
talk about not having the perfect selfie
the perfect lighting in a world where
that's what you're selling is to show
vulnerability inauthenticity I think if
you're gonna have any pictures of you
looking phenomenal if I looked as good
as all of you and I had all those
phenomenal photos I'd be waiting for
today that I have a huge goddamn zit on
my forehead and took a picture of that
because showing that real look at how
much real is in your feed versus how
much fake my more fake a lot more
perfect lighting a lot more oiled up
where's the real show me the real show
me the real that's what's gonna resonate
and so I think you need to balance
everything one way isn't enough create a
little cadence to having some offsetting
characteristics that make you way more
approachable than the alternative I get
eight thousand emails a year fifteen
thousand emails a year same guarantee
been doing it for nine months and I
don't see anything
I now have empathy for that because I'm
doing the same thing in working out I
can see little results but like if you
told me I was gonna work on every day
for 16 months and this is what I would
get I feel good about it but it's not
exactly what I want and that's what
you're going through in your business
like you've got to put in the work day
in and day out I work 12 15 17 18 hours
a day every single day right now I'm
filming this
my company's got a party going on like
you know what's going on there
but actually you know what come with me
actually this is perfect Arak here's
what's going on out there right and I
know the lighting is not good so sorry
you rock but
they're partying while I'm putting in
the work right now making this content
that that is the point the point is that
I'm putting in the work while everybody
else out there is enjoying themselves
that's it and so you got to put in the
work you want muscles you've got to
actually do the the weight you've got to
actually put in the work you want a
business there is no shortcut so the
progress you made and you made over the
last five ten to twelve years and your
fitness is exactly the same thing that's
going to happen in business there is no
overnight success there is no one year
you've done it well and now you have the
biggest business it's day in and day
I've been an entrepreneur since I was
eight I'm 40 now that's 32 years of
practice now you decide to really do it
doesn't happen tonight death in the work